le quartette pour le proche orient prête
à se reformer
face à l'escaladé des violences entre
israël et les palestiniens
objectif d'une conférence de presse
commune hier à moscou le secrétaire
général des nations unies et le chef de
la diplomatie russe invoque un processus
de paix multilatérale oui à nous sommes
totalement résolue à revitaliser le
quartet
nous sommes totalement résolus à
promouvoir toutes les formes de dialogue
entre les parties et avec d'autres
acteurs clés qui peuvent soutenir tout
ce qui est indispensable à la
désescalade
mais aussi à la revitalisation du
processus de paix qui se met depuis trop
longtemps
nous comptons sur le secrétaire général
en tant que coordinateur du quartet pour
essayer d'organiser une telle réunion le
plus rapidement possible russie etats
unis onu union européenne appelé à
endosser le rôle de médiateur pour
éviter que ces tensions ne se transforme
en une guerre à grande échelle
une crainte partagée par la france
membre de ce quartet le cycle des
violences en cours à gaza à jérusalem
mais aussi en cisjordanie et dans
plusieurs villes d'israël risque de
conduire à une escalade majeure en moins
de 15 ans la bande de gaza a connu trois
conflits meurtriers
tout doit être fait pour en éviter un
quatrième mais une mission qui pourrait
s'avérer compromise par la position des
états unis joe biden a d'ores et déjà
son idée d'éventuelles négociations
le président américain s'est entretenu
avec le premier ministre israélien
benyamin nétanyahou plaidant
l'apaisement le locataire de la maison
blanche affiche son soutien à israël
j'ai déjà eu une conversation avec lui
netanyahu il n'y a pas si longtemps je
publierai très prochainement une
déclaration à ce sujet mon espoir est
que ça soit fini aussi rapidement que
possible
mais israël a le droit de se défendre
quand des milliers de requêtes vols vers
son territoire
ce mercredi anthony blinken le
secrétaire d'état américain a exhorté le
président de l'autorité palestinienne
mahmoud abbas de mettre fin aux tirs de
roquettes
même attitude d'hier lors d'une réunion
en urgence du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu washington a fait barrage à
l'adoption d'une déclaration commune sur
ce conflit
démontrant une nouvelle fois la volonté
des états unis de jouer cavalier seul
sur le terrain israël aux palestiniens